what is it I'd say I'm quiet and relaxed
but most of all I'm the Freak of cook
and by that he means he loves and lives
to cook my name is my name is Sebastian
schwark I'm 25 and a member of the
Bundeswehr national culinary team Colton
dota dinosaurs cooking means you never
stand still you're always looking for
new ways to put your spin on a dish they
should not go from tell evidence to do
that he uses ingredients from all over
the world he couldn't have done that
before the Berlin Wall fell because back
then in the former East Germany many
ingredients were unavailable Vinnie
Mojica past the wall hadn't fallen I
probably still would have become a chef
but only for regional cuisine and the
DVD if I had to study German
reunification at school but either I
wasn't listening or I was daydreaming
outside school it didn't make an
impression I just been born born one
Sebastian was born in the Eastern German
port city of vis mark on the Baltic
coast in July 1990 a few months before
reunification he has an apartment in
vista mar but he's rarely there he
travels a lot something his parents were
unable to do in the former East Germany
type in divx been since i'm on the road
a lot this is a quiet place where I can
come and relax a bit and stroll through
the streets I muscley I feel at home on
the coast it's a mentality many people
here have that northern German charm but
I could live anywhere else as long as
the works going well I lost
whenever Sebastian's in Bismarck he
visits his grandmother Helga she lives
in the countryside outside town at 79
she not only lived through the Second
World War but also the division of
Germany and its reunification 25 years
ago she thinks things are much better
now and wishes she were 25 again for her
grandson her hearty northern German
cuisine was a great inspiration I don't
want that mathematical my grandma always
cooked a lot for me and she cooked well
when I came home from school there was
always a meal waiting for me I me select
complete that was a huge influence
having a good meal every day and a
different one every day and seeing that
it wasn't that hard to do so at some
point I started cooking but I still
haven't reached my grandma's standard
optical bin Amani huh even when he was
still at school Sebastian knew he wanted
to be a chef after an internship in a
restaurant in Bismarck after he finished
school he did an apprenticeship then you
joined the Bundys fair the German armed
forces as a chef many of his generation
study at university but Sebastian
doesn't believe you need a degree to
become a chef nahc much to view there's
nothing wrong with university but I
didn't need to study for years to become
a chef we don't cook better with a
university degree what you need is
enthusiasm and interest Sebastian is
among thirty-seven percent of his
generation who decided to get vocational
training forty-one percent of people
born in 1989 and ninety qualified for
university in contrast among the total
population that number is just
twenty-five percent so this generation
is highly educated music folks at victi
my success is very important to me I
want to build up something of my own and
be able to look back in 10 years and be
proud of what I've done one of
Sebastian's dreams was fulfilled last
May he became a member of the Bundys
fairs national culinary team they cook
at events like this one the German
government's open house day in Berlin
and they represent Germany at culinary
competitions all over the world the
13-man team includes the most talented
chefs in the Bundys fair it's really fun
of course we ask each other where are
you from but not whether it's east or
west my appetizer chef comes from
friends book Stefan comes from Berlin
and we have two people from Bavaria went
to from mecklenburg-vorpommern my pal
and me north rhine-westphalia everywhere
oh yeah you bite too tight whether from
eastern or western Germany it doesn't
matter after work Sebastian and his
fellow chef Christian head for the coast
good cuisine can be created using the
simplest of means Sebastian emphasizes
that when he's promoting his cookery
label freak of cook yes woohoo kempe now
whenever I'm on the road I try to post a
few photos on Instagram that gets the
word out to more and more people and
makes it better known kies etsy toned
assistant named yeah the kind of it for
Sebastian in his generation boosting
their own careers with the aid of social
networking is a matter of course
Mindless my greatest dream is for freak
of cook to be big and famous one day and
then maybe to publish a cookbook